what made it very important for me to
look deeper into islam was
our islamic history with regards to the
balkans meaning my country greece
originally
was part of the ottoman empire and the
greeks
until now they keep telling each other
how bad that time was and how all these
turkish ottomans how they actually raped
our women
killed our children and enslaved the
whole nation
and then i looked deeper into this
history and
my best friends in germany were turks so
i couldn't believe that these people
enslaved us
and these people thought that we were
inferior to them and all this stuff
so i looked into history and i found out
that indeed um i would say two-thirds of
what they were
telling us and teaching us was a lie
so i thought okay if they lied about our
history
what about lying about islam i always
have to love when people say read the
quran absolutely the quran is two-thirds
history
two-thirds of the quran is history now
if you look at the stories in the quran
there is always a lesson we have to
learn why
because the stories are not there just
to tell you some kind of it's not
entertainment
it's not entertainment it's a lesson
that we as humanity have to take from
them
and the stories in history is a lesson
to mankind the stories in the quran is a
lesson to the muslims
because if you look at the creation of
mankind adam
salam or power if we look at all these
developments from that time this is all
islamic history because in the end
adam islam was the first human kind
the first human the first messenger the
first prophet on earth
so that that's why islamic history
starts already so if you say
um what is islamic history i would say
human
human history mankind the history that
we as people have developed and
have come to the point that we are now
this is all islamic history because
in the end we were all born we are all
muslims you know that we're all born
muslims right it is the parents who
change us
so islamic history is everything so it
is
nonsense to say start in 600
go to the seer of rasulullah and start
from there and go on what about before
don't we need to know how the arabian
peninsula how the arabs were
what kind of people the arabs were okay
what they became with islam and how
islam changed them we need to know these
things
it doesn't start in 600 whatever it
doesn't start with the birth of
rasulullah
and it doesn't start with um with his
death and it doesn't stop with
the last skeleton um these are all
things that are part of our life and
should become part of our lives we need
to understand that
and all history is part of islamic
history
there's nothing like a muslim history in
islamic history no all of it is
i remember when i met my wife as i said
she's from south america
of african origin when i met her i
remember how people were saying in
greece
it's good you might have fun now but
what about your children later
and i'm like what do you mean what about
my children alhamdulillah
my children couldn't be more richer in
with regards to culture
civilization and background and
languages
speak several languages i speak several
languages my children grow up in a
multilingual environment
in a multicultural environment knowing
clearly that
their identity is being a muslim and it
does not matter
if you have a black background white
background greek background whatever it
might be
okay that's secondary
[Music]
you know you can do this without school
you already know that you can bring in
money
now the question is can you bring home
some paychecks and show that to mommy
and daddy
can you prove it that you can do it
because at the end of the day
they still have this traditional eastern
philosophy that you need to go to school
we came here we sacrificed our life
for you to go to college so you can get
this degree and
make this money whereas bro i keep
preaching this
you don't need school if you don't need
school if you're not trying to be a
doctor you're not trying to be a lawyer
you're not trying to be
some type of engineer
welcome back to the realest podcast in
the dunya once again
we are joined with the three muslims
myself
brother rami and brother angel and we
are joined with
a very special guest
so um before we get started for any of
our viewers who are not up to speed with
your amazing work masha'allah
why don't you give us a little bit of
your background an introduction
you can go as deep as your upbringing
you're coming into islam
or you can be as brief as maybe some of
the education that you've gone through
first of all i would like to thank you
reading i'd like to thank the
podcast martial it has been a great show
i've seen quite some of them
and i enjoyed uh i enjoy it it's very
very young
it's really for the young audience and i
think that's what we need we need that
um it is different to sit there with two
three other academics and have a
high level discussion and talk about the
latest books that we all wrote
and pat each other on each other's
shoulders so that's that's a totally
situation here and i i really think we
have to go on the level
of um the youngsters who would like to
um experience this dean in a different
way as i think i have experienced it and
i
experience it on a daily basis um
i always say listen one thing my my
background is i'm of greek origin
okay grew up in germany um
was there until i was 22 23 i moved away
from germany went to holland got to know
my wife there she is
originally from south america from a
country which was a dutch colony
not spanish and no portuguese but dutch
and i met her in amsterdam
and i told her listen i like your style
i like everything but you know what i'm
a muslim
and she was like okay and i was like
okay listen what do you mean with okay i
mean i thought you would run the
opposite direction
it was like no no you know i actually my
best friends were moroccans
i was like okay that sounds interesting
so they brought us together
that is my wife and she's my backbone
very important
so i was a muslim and i became muslim 30
years ago alhamdulillah
and what led me to islam is exactly my
work that i'm doing now
my first my the main push was actually
history
i used to obviously go to school as we
all did and at school it was a topic
which
really i personally had a lot of
interest in history
in many parts of the world i love
languages i love different cultures i
love different people
i wanted to go out i wanted to
experience the world and wanted to
travel
wanted actually a job in tourism and i
was actually working in tourism in
greece
for a while um and
i wanted to experience life and
islam was actually a belief in a god was
something was in the way
at the beginning i thought that
believing in god being a religious
person is quite boring
you know you can't really live life okay
and i thought that if you believe in a
god you must be somewhere
sitting at home not doing anything
reading the bible or the quran or
whatever it is
and that's about it but that's not
entirely true i discovered myself myself
after i'd looked into buddhism i've
looked into many other religions i've
traveled a lot i went to south america i
went to africa i went to asia
and i um i always came across islam and
i always pushed it away i was like come
on
what is this islam thing every time i
want to live life you know i don't want
isn't there something better than that
but what
made it very important for me to look
deeper into islam was our islamic
history with regards to the balkans
meaning my country greece originally was
part of the ottoman empire
and the greeks until now they keep
telling each other how bad the time was
and how all these
turkish ottomans how they actually raped
our women
killed our children and enslaved the
whole nation
and then i looked deeper into this
history and
my best friends in germany were turks so
i couldn't believe that these people
enslaved us
and these people thought that we were
inferior to them and all this stuff
so i looked into history and i found out
that indeed um i would say two-thirds of
what they were
telling us that teaching us was a lie
so i thought okay if they lied about our
history
what about lying about islam so
history brought me to islam and i
discovered that indeed
greek school where i used to go light
indeed about islam about the ottomans
about our history
so it's like this is crazy and i felt
betrayed
there was a time i was going around and
i was angry
i was upset i was upset on my teachers i
was upset with my
with the school system with education
system
and um i decided basically to look
deeper into islam
and decided to well i turned a bit
towards
arabic started learning arabic um
made me made me look more arab you know
with a thobe and all this stuff you know
all these things that
at the beginning when you become muslim
or when you come back to the venus we
all realize i think here
you start to be really like the
enthusiasm is over enthusiasm a very
very big enthusiasm for the deal
which is great because the dean is
fantastic however 30 years later of
course you come the more down to
to earth you realize that the dean is
great but you have to also live it
properly
so what happened that time i did
pushed away my greek roots because i
thought that was crazy and terrible what
they taught us there
but then i realized after several years
of getting into the dean and finding out
more about the dean i realized no
that we actually especially us rewords
we have to be the ones
to go back to our people and
actually tell them the truth now because
as i was lied to
others are lied to as well okay so now
we have to go back that is our task and
i realized that after again i traveled a
lot
i got married alhamdulillah and i
realized that that's what we have to do
not
not only the next generation that's
coming but also the people whom i'm
dealing with on a daily basis
they deserve to hear the truth and
that's when my life
changed drastically i became a lecturer
i started actually working at
universities working at colleges
um i used to go back to my parents a lot
which i at the beginning didn't
um because they were very negative
towards me of course and
that um made me i think also a better
person i realized that islam
is really not just reading the quran and
praying five times a day
but there's much much more to it and it
became my identity
and i'm very proud of it and that's what
i keep saying also in lectures i am
proud of having chosen to be a muslim
i am not proud of being greek i am not
proud of being white black yellow green
i cannot be proud proud of these things
you have to be proud of what you can
choose
i didn't choose to be what i am now i
didn't choose my color of the skin
i didn't choose the way i look i chose
to be a muslim
and this is what makes me proud
alhamdulillah and i keep saying that
also to born muslims one thing
look into the deen and then you choose
because you will
once end up at the point even if you are
born muslim
though you have to choose is this
something that i want to do and
and then you have to choose and once you
have chosen be proud of what you have
chosen
so again we can go on the whole time
talking about me i don't want to do that
but
that gives you an idea of how i entered
actually the dean
and what made me the person i am now
and uh i've in the last four five six
years
i've traveled a lot uh i've been to many
many countries and nearly all continents
actually and
uh have delivered a lot of lectures and
a lot of presentations with regards to
my story but also history in general
what does it mean why is it important
why do we need to learn history so all
this um
opened the doors for me to become a
muslim and to become a better muslim
humbly after 30 years
allah ah man masha allah for that intro
i just wanted to say that
if you were my history teacher growing
up i wouldn't look at history the same
way that i do today
because in the back of my mind i have
this boring teacher talking
he's doing it for money right he's not
even interested in uh in teaching
history he's just reading off of
powerpoint saying
you know there's lots of dates and and
cities and countries and
these different wars i'm just like come
on man like i'm just trying to pass the
course and then move on with my life
right but subhanallah i'm very
interested on like many of the viewers
might
might uh be in the same boat i also will
be
learning a lot too so this is going to
be one of those episodes where i'm
looking forward to uh
seeking a lot of knowledge insha'allah
charla indeed inshallah there's always
something history you're absolutely
right everybody thinks that it's
one of the most boring subjects actually
they exist in school curriculum
but the way it's delivered is a problem
as you mentioned yourself i mean it is
most of the times
some kind of boring old man sitting
there in front and
looking at their paycheck at the end of
the month and there is no real
enthusiasm for the topic there is no
real enthusiasm for what they're
teaching
and this really is a killer it is a
killer and it's a killer for most of the
people who
actually don't want to deal with history
later in their lives but
um there is much more to it and again
history is identity and
um not only as a muslim but especially
as a muslim of course
you see how history um the importance of
history as a muslim because
allah describes in the quran in various
verses in various ideas in the quran
the importance of history what he did
and i'm paraphrasing
what he did to the people in the past
would disobey him
what uh how he made the people rise and
others
fell and we see it on a daily basis and
i keep saying also don't forget the
people are up now
up there they will once fall that is
that is typical history that is what the
history of humanity is
um even our brothers in myanmar for
example now in burma
if you look at um the persecution of our
brothers in
that part of the world they once had an
empire brothers
these people in my own mind burma once
they were ruling an empire in the whole
southeast asia and now they are
persecuted of their refugees
but this is exactly what humanity is
that's exactly what's happening to us
we should never be arrogant and look
down on other people just because we
have reached a certain stage at this
moment in our life
because maybe in 10 years we are there
where the people
are we're mocking at this moment okay
and this history has shown exactly that
in history that is a typical result of
history
that once people were up there look now
look at greece the ancient greek
civilization
okay what a wonderful civilization i
mean
fantastic a lot of things that we can
take from them but look at greece now
you know we've become a third one
country if not even a fourth world
country you know if it does exist so
anyway
greece has become a country which nobody
everybody mocks everybody loves it now
one of the worst economic crisis ever
why is it like this
and many countries are like this many
peoples are like this many many
that's true throughout history
throughout humanity will find
subhanallah so and i think this is the
major
the main lesson we should take from our
history as people as humanity as
humankind
we have to understand that once we were
up there and we will
for sure fall that is the sunnah of
allah in history
no people has ever made more than a
thousand years
nobody nobody there's no empire that
lasted longer than a thousand years do
you know that
no empire has lasted a long time yet
that means
that um for sure
there is no empire that's going to last
longer than a thousand years okay that's
the sun of allah that's the sunnah of
history
alhamdulillah i just wanted to say uh um
the whole cliche history repeats itself
yeah you're right
yeah well it is a cliche but you know
it's pretty true
i remember things are appreciated for
some reason right yeah yeah yeah sure
sure i had a conversation with shahada
in london
and i remember when we met first the
very first day it was
really interesting because we didn't
know each other before we just heard
from each other
and i met him at his place he invited me
and um i asked him
actually it was him who said listen i
don't believe in the cliche
history repeats itself say okay you
would have to tell me why
it is a cliche it's true but there's a
reason why it has become like a ship
you know so he said that's that's a
typical historian speaking he said
because you look at it from your
perspective i said yes
but you look at his life from your
perspective
so everybody looks at life from their
perspective
so of course um somebody who is a
business owner has a different outlook
in life
than somebody who's a historian somebody
who is
i don't know a politician whatever else
so everybody has a
certain outlook in life and of course
that's how it is this is true
but shouldn't a historian be somebody
who actually should be listened to
because
a historian has looked in the past and
has seen the mistakes that we have made
as people
and we should try to avoid them and it
might sound like a cliche but
history repeats itself and unfortunately
it will repeat itself most probably
again because we
as people don't learn if there is
something that we have learned from
histories that we as people do not learn
okay and this is sad very sad
allah so i guess that kind of goes into
uh the importance of learning history
i'm trying to remember the saying uh
it's lifted my mind now but i found a
lie it really struck me when i first
heard it
if i remember i'll say inshallah but um
so aside from that what would be the
importance of learning history
many big people have spoken about um the
importance of history actually here
and it was as far as i remember napoleon
himself who said
one thing that we have learned from
history is that we haven't learned
anything
um that that's one thing allah
himself actually in the quran mentions
so many verses and
i would like actually to to to to just
quote some of them two or three of them
which extremely important okay and just
to promote
my book again the islamic history of
europe by the way this is
this is an alternative textbook um which
gives you an idea of what happened to
europe and how islam became part of
europe
and not something as they say alien to
europe
but if you look at allah in sura for
example
he says the following and i'm going to
read it out in english
have they not traveled in the land to
see the nature of the consequences for
those who disbelieve before them
they were mightier than these in power
and in the traces which they left behind
them in the earth
yet allah sees them for their sins and
they had no protection for allah
subhanallah i find it a powerful ayah
allah is talking about the people in the
past
and that he's talking about have they
not traveled so again
it's an order travel guys go and see
what has happened to the people before
me
before you go and see what happened to
these people
what happened to these civilizations
what i did to them
and another one said suraj for example
no nation can advance its time nor can
they postpone it
when the time is there the time is there
that's it that's the end of it
you cannot postpone it you cannot ask
allah to take you back
you cannot a people cannot change what
they did
that's it end of story that's it you
know they have
worked towards that and they get the
result
that there is others coming out towards
them um and last one surat
how many generations before them who
were more powerful than they
did we destroyed they explored the lands
was there any escape and that is a
reminder for whoever possesses a heart
or cares to listen and witness
subhanallah
so allah is telling us and there are
many many more passages like them of
course
allah is telling us in the quran look
into the past
and what does it mean look it to the
past means of course find out about the
past read about the past find out about
these people in the past
find out why they were up there and how
they felt
and take lessons from that take lessons
from them
so um if allah tells you that
um i always have to love when people say
read the quran absolutely the quran is
two-third history
two-third of the quran is history now if
you look at the stories in the quran
there is always a lesson we have to
learn why
because the stories are not there just
to tell you some kind of it's not
entertainment
it's not entertainment it's a lesson
that we as humanity have to take from
them
and the stories in history is a lesson
to mankind the stories in the quran is a
less to the muslims
so alhamdulillah i i every day and every
time we talk about this issue
i thank allah that he made me a muslim
alhamdulillah he opened my eyes and
opened my heart to that
and that i realized that there's more to
life than just entertainment
and that history opened my eyes to to
reality to the truth
so i'm again
so you mentioned islamic history right
or or history in the quran so would you
say that islamic history starts with
islam
or does islamic history kind of predate
that initial like beginning of islam
excellent question first of all we have
had several discussions with regards to
islamic history and muslim history is
there a difference what is muslim
history what is islamic history
um what goes around
people believe that um you should not
talk about certain things
they say that as as certain things
are not necessarily good positive for us
so let's not talk let's put it aside
so let's call this muslim history but
islamic history is everything that's
positive and good
that's not the case you know because if
you look at
the creation of mankind adam al-salam or
power
if we look at all these developments
from that time
this is all islamic history because in
the end adam islam
was the first humankind the first human
the first
messenger the first prophet on earth so
that that's why islamic history starts
already so if you say
um what is islamic history i would say
human
human history mankind the history that
we as people have developed and
have come to the point that we are now
this is all islamic history because
in the end we were all born we are all
muslims you know that we're all born
muslims right it is the parents who
change us
so islamic history is everything so it
is
nonsense to say start in 600.
go to the seer of rasulullah and start
from there and go on what about before
don't we need to know how the arabian
peninsula how the arabs were
what kind of people the arabs were okay
what they became with islam
and how islam changed them we need to
know these things it doesn't start in
600
whatever it doesn't start with the birth
of rasulullah and it doesn't start
with um with his death and it doesn't
stop with
the last calendar um these are all
things that
are part of our life and should become
part of our lives we need to understand
that
and all history is part of islamic
history
there's nothing like a muslim history in
islamic history no
all of it is
that's really profound i uh i can only
speak for myself but i never thought
about about it in that way subhanallah
i think it's uh really impactful allah
all of history is the kind of muslim
history or islamic
history or yeah subhanallah wow
so would you start from the beginning
that's beautiful man
i'm sorry i didn't mean to cut you off
go ahead no that is man because when you
said uh
you can only speak for yourself nah man
i agree i yeah
i never thought of it like that 100
percent like
my mind's pretty blown right now to be
honest with you
it's been like 10 15 minutes only yeah
we're just
i think no the point is what what what
fayette said before
you go through this boring school system
and you do what you're told to do
you want to pass your exam right you
want to finish high school and
you want to go out there then in the
world
but you have never been taught the
importance of what you're supposed to be
taught actually what you're supposed to
learn
um and you have never been pushed to
learn actually what you're supposed to
learn we have to learn we have to learn
from history for example it's just a
history
i mean math is important to be able to
count your salary for example it's
important
to be able to go to a shop and buy
things right that's math nobody will
deny that nobody would ever say no you
shouldn't learn how to count
very important in our lives um reading
writing very important in our life of
course you should be able to read and
write
be able to read a book or to be able to
just go to into a shop to read something
if you want to buy
very simple very clear things but would
anybody ever argue
or or would there be any any kind of
clear reason
why you should learn history many people
would say come on
that's in the past forget it very many
times i've heard this one it's in the
past forget it
i'm not living in the past i'm leaving
the present yes but in order to create a
future
you need to understand the past and our
african-american brothers for example
in in the states they know very well in
america north america
they know very well what i'm talking
about if your past has been taken away
from you
and you're trying to find your roots
you're trying to find
where you come from who you are where
you were from originally
that is an extremely important thing for
a person who doesn't know that
imagine maybe for somebody who's who
takes this for granted
we take it for granted but for somebody
like us let's say
we take it for granted we know where we
come from we know answers to you know
that that's nothing that it's of
importance of significance
but for somebody who don't know they
don't know where they come from
originally imagine that
you know they don't even know their
ancestors they don't even know where
what kind of cultures they actually came
from
the languages is this population and all
this this is massive
so for that reason as a muslim again
we need to know our past we need to know
where the people before us came from
and why they were punished by allah why
they were up there
why they fell all this is very important
extremely important but i think okay
yeah i want romney to continue but i
think that's um
[Music]
i think that's beautiful and i think
every single person has
that innate uh genuine interest to know
what happened before them
you know like when i was a kid like
maybe i didn't like school
probably no kid really like school to be
honest instead of playing with your
friends and going to the playground
and recess and all that but whenever i
would be
in history class and they'd be showing
us something about
uh maybe the romans the greeks the
egyptians i'll be like oh
this is interesting like this is this is
some cool stuff
and man like i'm i'm 27 years old now
i'm puerto rican and if you look in the
puerto rican culture like we're
we're mutts we are a blend of like
africans
uh portuguese people native americans
the tainos
and all these other things so it's like
i don't even know where i come from
you know so i think i think that's real
i think that's beautiful and i think
that's a genuine interest that every
single human shares
i think that's something that pushed me
also towards why i love south america
and latin america
i remember when i met my wife as i said
she's from south america
of african origin when i met her i
remember how people were saying in
greece
it's good you might have fun now but
what about your children later
and i'm like what do you mean what about
my children alhamdulillah
my children couldn't be more richer in
with regards to culture
civilization and background and
languages
speak several languages i speak several
languages my children grow up in a
multilingual environment
in a multicultural environment knowing
clearly that
their identity is being a muslim and it
does not matter
if you have a black background white
background greek background whatever it
might be
okay that's secondary okay that's
secondary and they have learned that
throughout their life mashallah my
oldest one is 22 now mashallah
um who is looking by the way to get
married but my younger wife is already
married masha he's 20.
so my younger one is 28 is married and
he got married to a girl who is half
pakistani as
masha'allah i love this i love this that
is humanity again
at its best you know that is humanity is
the best
what is this trying to go back to the
people and mary you can just marry
somebody from of your own kind what
nonsense is that
you know who came on this idea that you
have to marry somebody from the same
tribe
from the same village from the same town
the same
country you know and then amongst
themselves even you see people not
wanting to marry from the same country
because they're from the same tribe what
nonsense
how do you come with something like that
allah has created us
in different tribes in different colors
in different in order to recognize each
other
to come close to each other to actually
find out about each other
that is the beauty of life beautiful
you know and that's why i think when i
look at people who have never traveled
for example
i pity them i pity them i honestly
picture them people have never traveled
people have not experienced other
cultures and other religious
other other languages i pity them i'm
sorry but you haven't experienced life
you haven't you haven't and it is
exciting life in itself is exciting
and um i really i feel full of energy i
mean i'm
i just turned 49 by the way just some
days ago two three days ago
so um many people say you wouldn't say
you wouldn't tell that you're 49 you
wouldn't tell it you're nearly 50.
um i'm full of energy still and i i love
being in contact with people socializing
and
really being out there and i think i
would die if i had no if i had a day
that i would have to stay alone at home
or whatever i would die
i think work is very important to me but
work that i love
is very important to me and family is
very important to me
and having this rich
surrounding that i have i mean if you
were if you spent a week
in my home you will hear within a week
you will hear
six different languages okay you will
see um um you will have what's up
context from all over the world you will
see my
my mother being from germany my sister
being somewhere in holland
you know my contacts that i have brought
in asia
it's crazy and i love this this is
something i love i feel that i
like vibrant it's it's a vibrant
lifestyle and i love it
and as i said i would i think i would
die if i didn't have a chance to do that
um
and that's why i find it extremely
important what we said before that uh
discover each other and
and live with each other in a way and i
think a family the family should have
this chance and
the possibility to to to to have a very
vibrant
family life masha'allah otherwise i
would say it's boring
it's boring and i think rediscovering
and discovering your roots and
discovering your history and everything
is all part of it
and so that's why i think i've ended up
where i am now mashallah and
i've become independent myself actually
i used to work for colleges and
universities people
i'm now working on my own for the last
four or five years
and i'm loving it i'm absolutely i
cannot imagine anything else
so that's it i think i think
the profound effect that geography has
on history right because you were
talking about history and now now we're
talking about geography and it all comes
together
yeah absolutely yeah absolutely
yes absolutely it's very very important
i mean um
people forget this that that when we
talk about
history we're talking about different
cultures different different backgrounds
different peoples
and and their history and history is not
just a specific type of history it is
as we said before every type of history
every people's history is history
and should should be given special
attention
and every people have had had actually
history in the past
allah has given everybody the chance
once
to be up there and they all once fell as
we know you know the roman empire the
ancient greeks
the egyptians uh the babylonians the
assyrians all of them once a massive had
a massive
empire what happened to them they fell
of course and that's the main
thing that we have to learn from them
um we were just talking about uh in in
our last uh in our last session you're
talking about how allah says in the
quran that
he created different types of people so
that they can get to know each other
subhanallah and now we have this like
tribalistic manner and nationalistic
manner subhanallah
um i actually i was rejected because
you're talking about marriage
and marrying within or without your
tribe and all that
i was rejected uh once a few years back
because um the people were afghan and i
was palestinian
just like just that alone and i was like
her family right
yeah yeah i was not alone i was like
subhanallah you dodged the bullet bro
yeah i did not but um
it's a real problem nowadays it's a real
issue
but um subhanallah what i was gonna ask
before was where should a person
looking to study history start would
they literally start with adam al-islam
in the quran
where it depends no i wouldn't do that
um it depends a lot i mean you do have a
certain interest let's say you're
interested
in even if you start with yourself let's
say you come from the middle east
take a look at the history of the middle
east i would start there take a look at
actually
um what is your background where do you
come from
and from there on i would not move my
way around so
let's just say egypt let's just say i'm
egyptian and i'm looking into
the history of egypt or the background
that egypt had
there you will discover first of all
that egypt was not always a country as
it is nowadays
that it is part of africa that is part
of the middle east
and that again opens your mind to move
on you from egypt will automatically
have to move to the middle east you will
automatically have to move to africa
so there you are and you're on two
continents automatically that brings you
further into their different history
you find out that african history for
example or
thousands of years millions of years of
african history
which people totally deny nowadays by
the way um you find out that and that in
itself will keep you very busy
and you will see yourself i mean if you
are a person who is more interested
in in what's happening what's going on
in the west
then you will automatically move on
towards the history of
of of the west or certain countries in
the west and so
but i would start with myself i would
start with your background your roots
start with that and that will lead you
towards other
uh cultures and people how do you find
that out
because i've been listening i did the i
did the ancestry.com i think that was
the
dumbest thing ever man because it's like
it just it told me something that i
could look on google and figure out for
myself
but like how would one find out their
boots if they're mutts well look
in your case mashallah you're from
puerto rico i mean
puerto rico as you said yourself you
know it's a mix of people
african european whatever else different
origin spanish of course
so um if you go back if you look at
puerto rico itself
the country going back to 200 years
let's say um
you go to spain you go to alan delus you
know you go to
this part of the world as well and you
will find out the architectural
background for example in puerto rico
as in mexico as in many parts of south
america you will find
the typical island andalusian style okay
or
architecture so that again
will bring you closer closer to your
home country you will understand oh
that's where these people came from
that's what they brought with them
and that was al-andalus al-andalus
basically was a muslim
empire muslim muslim region of the world
in europe
that is in europe and that brings you
closer to hey how did islam come to
europe
what happened there actually we're not
talking about the middle east you know
we're talking about europe we're talking
about spain
portugal and these very people came over
to the caribbean and to the americas and
they brought with them
islam as well as they brought all their
cultures with them and that's what
developed into what is not
known as puerto rico and next to this
one you're also an american citizen
so being puerto rican is part of of the
us
so you see how the one brings the other
okay
so and that's how you find out and again
i mean alhamdulillah we're all
open-minded people here so
just look further that will bring you
into more many many more other things
and many
many more details history is massive you
just need to know where to start and i
think ideally
start with it start with puerto rico
look at actually actually how was
puerto rico so-called discovered by the
europeans by the spaniards first
and what happened before might there be
that there was a muslim history before
and there was by the way muslim history
before indeed you know in the caribbean
south america north america you will
find even in canada
there have been muslims muslims were
there before christopher columbus
arrived
actually everybody was there before
christopher columbus columbus is just
taking the
you know the everybody thinks columbus
the one who discovered the world
but in the end everybody was there
already before long before christopher
columbus even the vikings imagine that
even the vikings
they were in north america before
christopher columbus so
so basically all the these these ideas
that we have nowadays
and are celebrated even you know i mean
that's ridiculous i have to laugh every
time when they celebrate columbus day
whatever they call it
um i mean what are you celebrating you
know the genocide of
of two continents of our of peoples what
are you celebrating that what exactly
are these people celebrating you know
um that in itself is already crazy
so yeah this is all part of your history
as well this is all part of your
specific history
of course the other two brothers they
have also another background however
their histories as well um it's also
part of canadian history
so yes this is all part in canada and
itself
being i respect canada very much
mashallah it's really a very
it's a country that is very open has
become by the way okay let's not
it's not a country that was like this it
has become an open country nowadays
tolerance towards other people and other
religions and cultures and everything
martial are beautiful however it wasn't
always like this
okay so the white only policy in
australia also existed
in canada once okay when they wanted
just white people coming from europe
right
um but as uneducated as his people were
and still
are um they took white people from
europe but they
forgot that these white bosnians and
turks who came over were actually
muslims
so now if you look at australian society
for example
you see a massive amount of muslims
coming from the bolton peninsula
having established islam in australia
although they didn't come from indonesia
asia or africa whatever else so you see
that shows
europeans in general are very uneducated
people with regards to people and
cultures
because they always felt themselves
being better than others
this superiority complex that the
european has and i think i can say that
as a european as a double european
um this is something no other people
have nobody else has
and i always um say when when allah
created
iblis when actually allah created adam
alayhi salam and then he please saw him
what did he please say why do you do
that allah
why are you doing that i mean do you
need to do that we are paraphrasing of
course
and i think i believe that iblis was a
european
you know so
i believe you know if you look at where
europeans have
gone and what they have done honestly
honestly honestly honestly what exactly
were the positive results of european
arrival
in the rest of the world um
supposedly it was uh supposedly they
were going to spread
christianity but it was really to
humanize
riches colonialism yeah
yes absolutely i mean the idea was the
white man's burden isn't it
so they felt that they had to go to
africa to spread civilization which is
part of
well they thought christianity was that
so there's the same they did
they went and destroyed whole whole
entire continents i mean the same in
australia
and the same in in the americas so what
exactly i mean we have created europeans
have created now
um a world um
which is a copy of europe in many ways
um
and it is actually quite a miracle we
still have black people in africa
but that most probably only
because they are quite resilient okay
whereas others
died away you know if you look at native
americans for example if you look at
australian aborigines
you see that they're living like animals
basically in in ghettos
in australia and in the americas or
whatever but
africa alhamdulillah still the only
continent that still has african people
black people more or less
whereas in asia alhamdulillah we also do
have some asian people there
but other countries have become actually
half turned are turning already
so um it is honestly subhanallah
i believe that um
europeans have really created a lot of
problems that we have nowadays in the
world
absolutely absolutely and you cannot fix
that anymore
how can you fix a continent
country an area territory which was
built on blood
what do you do how do you go back
okay i mean
puerto rico was built on blood okay
the caribbean was built on blood north
america was built on blood south america
was good on blood
they destroyed and killed the original
people who were living there
and to replace them with another people
and you know that one of the biggest
theory of these right-wing
extremists people in europe for example
who are talking about
the replacement theory they know what
they're talking about because their
ancestors did it already to others
so they're now saying muslims come over
to europe
and soon we will be replaced by these
muslims because they're muslim hordes as
they call them
muslim [ __ ] coming to europe replacing
uh you know raping our women
or marrying them making them muslim
these are things that they're saying
okay and soon the white european
um majority will become a minority
this is a typical uh belief
of the the right-wing media by the way
and
if you look at america if you look at
the idea
uh that that white people actually in in
america have a problem with um
other people coming over and migrating
simply because they are scared that
soon they will become a minority which
they are actually already
um somehow because of their superiority
feeling believing that there's something
better than
people of color okay um
that of course is something that has
been created throughout the last
centuries
okay we've come to that point now
man i
it's crazy because look i my mind is
wild i i don't got to explain that to
you guys but my mind is wild
and whenever i have free time i start to
like think very
like in depth into things and sometimes
i might even go into
do some research but um what you said
about like just the mix and all this
stuff that's happening
it makes me think of this one thing that
i've been thinking about for years now
and that's the fact that you have
different
races and different uh people living in
different areas in this world right
you got some people living in the
mountain areas you have some people
living in the tropics some people living
in the sahara the desert
some people living in antarctica like
all this stuff you have all these
different uh ecosystems
and when people live in an ecosystem
their body adapts
and they have certain traits that allow
them to survive and just
live better in these circumstances like
people who live in the mountains
i know that a an adaptation as their
nose
becomes more more narrow so they can
actually take in that air
and it won't affect them the same way
they um they can handle
the um the air pressure i believe it's
the air pressure i might be
you know mixing that up but then you
have people in the desert and supposedly
people who
come from the desert are more taller
or at least just long and lanky they
have long lengthy bodies
so that they can sweat and cool
themselves down and they have
a bit wider noses so that they can uh
get oxygen with all the heat and the
well i'm not going to say humidity
because it's dry but you understand
and then people who live in the tropics
they have stuff then you have the
africans who live in the desert
i mean or in the sahel look at their
skin
look at their skin that's that's a
perfect indicator right there
and like what you're saying perfectly
ties into this where it's like
if you have all these different people
that have
combined together like for instance a
puerto rican
it's a it's a mud it's a mixture of all
these things like well what do they have
what what are the traits that they have
and then you got these other people over
here what traits do they have like i
don't know but
that's what you invoked in mind and i
think
i think that's crazy
it makes you think about your people
right it makes you think about yourself
but look the thing is if you look at
puerto rico's society or society in
south america the caribbean you see that
they've become obviously
unnatural if you want to use that term
unnaturally mixed
now you you just you know it was
obviously a forceful
situation history they took people from
africa just put them there to work for
them
you white people where the european
people had a certain
interest of being there they took people
from india
put them and so on and so on so this mix
developed not because of migration of
natural migration
which is a natural thing in humanity and
mankind but it was
a forceful situation and they created
um nations and countries which again the
idea of a nation is something a very new
is the last
the last 200 years that we developed
having an idea
of a nation the way that we think of a
nation a closed border
or a close territory with borders around
surrounding them
and uh people who have the same language
the same culture same religion
in this territory which is an an an
ideal
okay of of the french revolution 1789
and after them they wanted actually
people to believe in the ideal of a
nation belonging to a nation
being part of of a nation territory
so that we all all these people of this
specific nation speak the same language
have the same culture the same
background
but this is again is is it's not true
that it's not there is no nation like
this on this planet
not one nation you can show me which is
homogeneous which is
one nation having the same people the
same color the same religion
not one nation does exist not one so
we're living in nation states nowadays
which is unnatural this in itself
is unnatural the the the way that we're
living nowadays that we've developed
is unnatural you know because there is
no nation like this that
has one one people one nation it's
nothing like that so
the natural thing is exactly what allah
describes that's why he did
he he created a different type of people
okay
so we are supposed to actually recognize
each other and you know
be with each other in contact and and
learn from each other
that is definitely a part of why we are
developed where we are
um we were created in in different ways
okay but in the end we're all the same
people i mean we all have noses and eyes
and legs and then
feet and everything so it's all the same
in the end it's just that specific
you know as you mentioned before indeed
that
we adopt to our surrounding and and
that's why certain people have this
color and that color whatever yes
but in the end adam alaihisalam was
created by
all people's color by all by the sand by
the different types of standard
different
um part of the earth
so that in itself again tells you that
we are all one race
we are all one race there is nothing
like different races
there's one race we're not different
races it's a human race
you know but we can learn from different
cultures and different civilizations we
should never feel
that because i belong to a certain
culture or a certain civilization
i know everything now and i can teach
everybody else anything no
we can learn from each other from the
deepest bush people we can learn
yeah watch someone take what you said
about adam being uh all races out of
context
and they'd be like oh well adam was all
racist so therefore he was a rainbow so
therefore he was gay
and therefore lgbtq
i mean that's the world we live in today
oh my god okay someone will do that
someone will do that
oh my god okay okay
that was not at all my idea but okay
yes yes nowadays that might happen yes
that that might happen yeah
this shakes at this therefore that
equals this and then
now i don't know man i've heard this too
many times man
you're right yeah one plus one equals
five
mm-hmm well it's not too far away from
the christian
one plus one is three isn't it
one one plus one plus one is one isn't
it
somebody commented for the
trinitarianism that it's one times one
times one equals one
is it okay i was like who told you you
gotta multiply it bro
so they have to always justify something
of course one time there's one that was
one yeah
that's right that's going so yes
but does anybody of you have a christian
background here
i grew up where you pointed at fire
romney
oh on my screen you're down here okay
yeah i um i was born catholic
okay and um i kind of
went into christianity throughout my
life um several years but it was like
there was always something that
prohibited me
from fully being immersed in it and
i feel like it was because something
inside of me knew
like no this isn't exactly it
this isn't it and i can feel that it's
not
it because when i read the quran
and i started to meditate after reading
it like
there was no if and's a bust there was
no doubts
it was like this is it and as soon as
like i
rationalize in my head like this is it
oh man
the feeling is amazing isn't it yeah you
know it's amazing
i think nobody was ever going through
that with will understand that
nobody's ever experienced oh it's true
yeah i'm not sure i said no no i mean i
fully i i'm just thinking back 30 years
ago
and i thought i would never be able to
experience it again but at this very
moment
at this very moment as we're talking
about it i experienced my very first
time i made sujud
i went i was in in aachen in germany in
a small town where i grew up
and we're islamic centered and
i decided myself once on a jumar to just
follow these muslims to just go there to
this place
and just make rokusudu you know just
just go up and down
i i was in my suit and i started crying
i was like what you doing man what's
wrong
you know what's the matter with you you
know what's what's going on
you know what is going on the feeling
you know um you cannot describe it you
got
it's the same like somebody asked me how
was your hajj come on honestly no
don't ask me no you can't you cannot
explain that you cannot explain that
this is not something
when i saw the car about the first time
in my life
i just broke down i fell down and i
started crying and i don't know if
anybody had the chance to go to mecca
but when you have please do i just
broke down and cried and i have no idea
why
okay it was a brother actually
i was um the first time i was there was
in jeddah
and from gender we went to mecca the
very first time with my family
and again as i said i just broke down
and started crying but the second time i
went back after many years
i went for hajj there was an angolan
brother next to me
and we were walking and um suddenly i
was
in the haram and suddenly there in front
of me there it was that was
the kaaba i just fell down again and i
just cried it was like no worries
just cry let it all out said to me just
cry let it all out that's exactly what
you were waiting for
that is what you were waiting for to be
here and just let it all
out okay and he just he just let me he
i don't know how long it was i was just
crying like a little child
really it was a long time that something
like this happened
okay and i was just standing there and
crying actually i was
lying on the ground crying and he just
let me do it
just go ahead and don't feel embarrassed
don't feel embarrassed that's how it is
let it all out subhanallah
so this is an experience that nobody
nobody who has never experienced that
himself will never understand so you
cannot explain
you can't explain impossible
in my reverb video because i have my own
youtube channel
and i made a reverb video just kind of
explaining everything and i tried my
best
to put it into words what i felt and
what i experienced
and to this day like it doesn't do it
justice like when i hear it again and i
hear myself i'm like
that wasn't really it though like it was
just it was so much more than that
and then man i have moments where i'm
i'm doing uh salah and i have i'm just
hyper present like my mind is just
completely
tuned in to everything and like i still
can't explain
what i'm experiencing i could try to but
it's
it would be it would be a disservice
for me to try to explain to everyone oh
look this is happening here and then
this over here and this over here
because it's
it's never going to be exactly what i
experienced and it's like
i don't remember who but i spoke to a
brother and he's like oh
was it um i think it was sheikh fahad
who said this where he was like
um whatever you think allah is
that's not it it's like you you can
never conceive it just like
um maybe you could experience allah but
you can never put it into words
you could experience something like this
and you can never put it into words but
i think that's beautiful yeah
yeah again you will never be able to put
it towards i don't think so
and i've stopped actually when i'm asked
like how was your heart or what
you can you know experience in yourself
you cannot that's it
no absolutely not absolutely but this is
the beauty of the deal and this is what
i said at the beginning also the dean is
beautiful
it is so beautiful i don't know it's
you know i remember my first discussions
i've had
with uh my mother for example when i
tried to explain to her
listening to the other
how do you explain that you know um
and especially having clearly i mean
she's a clear hater
she has a clear hater towards islam um
but
what it has changed from the last couple
of years she even said to me
i've realized that just intelligent
people accepted
she said to me i realized that just
people who have become muslim
are intelligent people she said to me i
said mom you're also intelligent
so what's going on with her what about
that you know
i got her that far actually merely she
was lying in bed i remember
and i said mom listen what is the
problem to say the shahada
you believe in all this what i tell you
right so
you see how my life is isn't my family
life better than
or don't you want me to be the way i am
am i not a happy person don't i have a
good family life
so she said yes so i said so what's your
problem exactly so say shahada
she had the finger up and subhanallah
shaitaan put it down
subhanallah subhanallah
this is unbelievable you know
and i'm really happy alhamdulillah that
my wife's mother my mother-in-law
died as a muslim on the deathbed she
said alhamdulillah
but this woman subhanallah this woman
always
was open towards islam i remember how
she would come to our home
and she would tell us what they do in
suriname for example
do you know that i mean in in suriname
they would close the windows they would
call their children inside with mahrez
so when the time for maghrib
has come they would call their children
inside and i'm like
why were you doing that i said you know
she said it's the time
for the devils she was saying to me
i said mom do you know that i said this
is what we believe in islam
the time of shaytan she said yes i know
that my ancestors were believing that i
said
you know that your ancestors were muslim
you know that
you know that you have lost your
heritage you know that you know
she said yeah it might be it might be i
don't know where i'm from originally
we don't know that we were taken from
africa we don't know said yes
so and alhamdulillah this woman said
shahadah
on her deathbed alhamdulillah
alhamdulillah and i'm very happy about
that
really and that's what i keep telling my
wife i said don't be don't cry
be happy alhamdulillah be happy don't
cry
don't cry it's good the way she went
very good humble
she deserved it so you know subhanallah
you know there's so many things you know
if you think
of of life subhanallah i mean
what is what are the hundred years let's
just say 100 years of our life
you know what do we have to do in this
life what is our what is the meaning of
life you know is it running after women
is it having throwing one part after the
other you know all these things we have
done that you know we have all done that
here i'm very sure
throwing one party after the other and
then you wake up the next morning you
think like what the heck did i do
what is all this about okay what did i
do
what's the meaning of life you know is
this the meaning of life
honestly and then you become 40 50 60
and then what then what you know
so subhanallah
no i think i asked it i asked i asked um
where should someone start learning
history and he said they start with
their own
where they come from okay okay yeah
subhanallah
you know what i'm what i'm thinking
what's going through my head
that we have plans but allah's plan is
always better for example
i had no idea who this wonderful
you know speaker that we have in front
of us just
telling us and showing us all these
different things giving us these
paradigm shifts this new way of thinking
and i'm sure you yourself you you
haven't heard of us
but somehow somewhere you know one of
your assistants alhamdulillah
found us on on youtube got in touch with
us and now we're here today
everything happens for a reason yes
absolutely we know that yes and it's
like
we didn't know how much we needed you on
this podcast
for insha allah so many people to see
until we got you here we didn't even
know you existed and
it just allah's plan
[Music]
man yes yeah
let me let me let me throw on one last
thing
when you when you become present and and
cognizant of allah's signs
that's a game changer too so for example
we had uh somebody comment hey you
should get dr steph karis on your show
and we were like okay i've never heard
of that but everyone you know recommends
these people and then i i look into them
but
you know i haven't maybe uh looked in a
into you
and uh i usually don't look into most
people because usually we have
you know you know well ahead of weeks of
just episode topics and ideas
somebody else commented i was like okay
whoa that's enough two
two two people commented okay another
one another one another one and then
you became one of the most you know
commented person
to get on the show alhamdulillah and
then uh
i think even yesterday we got another
brother um he's a youtuber
he has you know a lot of a lot of subs
we got him on too
and i i posted like a snippet of that
and somebody commented on that
you should get dr steph curious again
and
yesterday i already already knew like we
have it for today
it's it's a pleasure being here honestly
it's a pleasure as i said before because
i like the ideas i mean i like the way
that
the show goes it's not some kind of um
as i said having some academics there
and talking about you know the books
that we wrote and how proud we of
ourselves
no there's more to it it goes very deep
and i like actually the way that it has
moved we're talking about our
experiences and angel
especially mentioned his experience
which i i understood fully
i i am there you know i'm like i'm with
him
and i think by the way it has clicked
very much but when i was too much
so really i mean i can really see that
so
um the experience that we have had in
our lives you know
why what pushed us towards islam um
and why we are at the stage that we are
now um they're so similar
um and i think many river brothers
understand that and see that themselves
and
um it is it's it's it's fascinating it's
really fascinating and it is always
something different when you talk to
somebody who has accepted the
the d in the faith um it is um it's
it's it's it's yeah again you cannot
express this in words i mean it's
absolutely amazing really and uh
yesterday's
episode that we had with uh with the
brother um with the youtuber when
you know angel asked him a question
period point blank
are you at peace and you know what we
talked about that's not relevant my
point is
after that recording i was just
meditating i was just thinking
and reflecting on you know as i usually
do based on our previous recordings
and i was just thinking like if somebody
asked me that
before islam you know in my jahilia
are you at peace i would say no i would
say the same thing that most people
would say
no after islam see i'm not going to say
i'm going to go to jannah because nobody
has guarantee that they're going to go
to jannah right we can all
and i like that because it keeps us down
to earth and humble
but if no matter what i've done in the
past i've repented whatever
if somebody asked me right now as a
muslim as a believing muslim
not blind faith not you know
brainwashing anything but
firm who i am now if somebody asked me
are you at peace
100 times 100 i'm gonna say yeah 100
and and i'm sure you guys can all agree
and it's an insane feeling like
you said um you know you have to
experience it and
believe that and go through that
experience it's not something that you
know
we should tell people oh you know one
day you know it's going to feel like
this
i'm going to ask you after the shahada
it doesn't end with each other like once
you truly get that feeling it clicks
it's surreal subhanallah and it's not to
say
that we're not going to experience the
difficulty
that we won't experience depression that
we won't experience anxiety that we
won't experience anger that we won't
experience
tough times but it's just that we
experience them
but we have the peace that comes
through the prayer and through the deen
and like i'm sorry but i'm not listen
i'm not gonna talk
bad i'm not gonna say anything bad about
the guy that we were entering
because i love to do i love dude i've
been watching his content for
years and i pray for him you know i hope
he does find peace i hope
allah does grant him that peace but it's
like dude
anytime i speak to someone who's
christian
catholic buddhist hindu
um new age spiritual people
like all these people they may have
their own little things but it's like
they still don't say that they're at
peace they still
identify so much with the trials that
they're going through with
everything and it's like yeah they might
have little practices they might have
all these things they might even have
prayer
but they're still so identified with
the struggle and the dunya that it's
like once
someone becomes a muslim and i should
say
not even muslim but like a real
muslim and and i it's weird for me to
say that but like
you can you can have two muslims right
you have one who's
real like he's he's proper like he's
he's he has a dean
he believes and he's actually living
that lifestyle he's living that through
and then you have someone who says
they're muslim
but they're not actually practicing
they're not doing anything they're over
here
doing whatever they want as if they
weren't muslim so it's like
these two muslims are clearly different
and the person who's actually
living it through they're going to
experience the peace
that comes from the religion from the
deen and from that lifestyle
and again i just i think it's crazy
yeah absolutely i mean this this again
these are all things that we're
expressing now
is what you feel is it's a lot it's a
lot that
you cannot express actually you cannot
utter it's something that you feel and
that's something that you can just
understand
when you are in the dean and the dean
makes you a very special person
the dean makes you a very special person
indeed of course that does not mean
that we're looking down on other people
that does not mean that we're
discriminating against other
people that does not mean that that's
not what we're saying here
and every time i was also asked by other
greeks for example so
what had how has your life improved
actually
what has become better i say
how long how long do we have time to
discuss that you know
how long do you want to sit down and
discuss that with me
um the the simple way
just look at me just just have a
conversation i just find out
actually um um um how
stable i feel how balanced i feel in my
life
i actually feel very energetic rather i
would say
balance but um this is all part of the
deed this is all that the dean gave me
this is all something that
um i never had before okay i never had
before
and i mean i was very energetic i was
young i enjoyed life as i said you know
according to the understanding of what
life
enjoying life is for for for the average
westerner
but there is much more to life and this
is what we're enjoying now i'm enjoying
now myself
and this is what i'm trying to give to
my children and this is something we
need to do we need to get through
to our next generation that of course
they need to experience themselves they
need to make the mistakes
they need to learn from mistakes no
doubt about it that's how it should be
but they should also listen and take
something from our experience and
understanding from the
from the dean and from our life and this
is
the task that we have now and that's a
big task
a lot to do yeah and again like you said
it's something that
is experienced it's not something that
you can hear someone say and be like ah
okay
you know so and it sucks that it
it is that way it's amazing because we
have to have our own
um subjective experience
but it kind of sucks where you have a
person who hasn't had the experience
but they're closed off to the experience
because you can't fully express it to
them but i feel like even if you could
express it to them
they still wouldn't catch on to it you
know and it's like all they would have
to do
is experience it for themselves but
they're so closed off
yeah yeah absolutely
there's so much to still talk about but
um
i think uh we should come back those are
fascinating
nonetheless to the series
and and and this is this is a very
important time i think i wanted to say
that as well
very important time to really reflect
upon yourself reflect upon the last year
reflect upon your life what we do at
home um
we always get the children and ourselves
we just sit down shortly before ramadan
we put down three points that we want to
reach by the end of ramadan
so three aims that we have
that's what we want to let's say for
example i want to learn
surah so by the end of ramadan i want to
know this surah
or by the end of ramadan i want to have
prayed with her okay
and i want to keep it running after
basically i would like to go on with
winter
so it's something that should make you a
better person and try to keep
the aim low so that it you can fulfill
it otherwise it's
it's disastrous if you cannot do that it
will destroy actually ramallah
but try to keep it low just simply you
know learn a small
surah or read a part of the quran every
day or whatever else comes up to you you
know
so this is something that tried to do
that inshallah this is i think a good
time to
to say it now at the beginning of
ramadan
prepare for ramadan in such a way and
and and
i'm looking forward to that and i'm just
hoping that ramadan will be better than
last year
when we had the whole corona issue when
it was very very difficult the mosque to
actually close that time
until at least now they're open how is
it over there i mean north america now
at this moment we have
yeah we're back into lockdown again back
to los angeles
right a week before ramadan uh
the government just said we're gonna
close for one month
you tell me you tell me if they're
connected i don't know
yes what to say what to say i don't know
i mean i get it
people won't be social distancing you
know if thought i get it but
i don't know man i think this is really
blown out of proportion now it's like
have you got the vaccine yourself and no
no
and i think i'm not sure if this is 100
but to go to do hajj now you need a
vaccine
yes uh according to i think the last
thing that i heard from mufti bank i
think it was even
from saudi
yeah and that's the reason why actually
we would all have to do it in the end
they tell you it's voluntary what do you
mean volunteer where's the voluntary
issue there when you when you have to do
it to travel i mean who doesn't travel
nowadays you know so
i need to travel for my work next to
this one as you said if i wanted to go
to saudi if i want to go for hajj again
i wanted to go just to to to visit it
you need to have the vaccine
so there you go yeah i don't like that
because
it's kind of like the jews in the
holocaust they mugged them
to know that they were the jews so you
get the vaccine and then you're getting
this thing on your passport
that's letting them know hey this person
took
the vaccine like and we don't know what
the vaccine does and
we probably never will until like years
and years from now
but literally like you are marked you
are mocked
yeah yes i don't know what this is going
to lead to at the end i don't know the
result of that but it is really
difficult
um the whole issue of the vaccine the
whole issue of this corona issue
i don't know what to say honestly i
don't know it's difficult
but we do have to adjust the new
normality that's what they kept saying
before already
there's gonna be something new a new
normality forever it will never go back
to the way it was
so some people some people say that the
um
the the vaccine like when you
you get the passport that says like you
had the vaccine
they say that that that not only are you
marked but they call that the mark of
the beast that it's like the time
of the mark of the beast of like the end
times and everything so like it's kind
of loud
i hope it's not but let's be honest
things have already been going downhill
um i i think it's safe to say it's not
the literal like sign
of one yeah yeah but i will say i will
say
if i had to pick between you know you
know the end of times you know
the jab all that that's far away or you
know
we're very we're approaching the end i
would go with ladder 100
there's no denying you know there's not
going to be
too much time left but who knows man so
wanna it's not in our place to say
when or where but it's the way things
are going with this covet
they're getting in the way of you know
it's not volunteer you don't need to get
it
you know you can still live your life
but i can't really do that if i can't
practice my religion
do pilgrimage i can't really go you know
there's there's one thing saying i can't
go to my school
right for example i'm in first year of
grad school i finished year one
and i've never even seen my campus right
all schools are shut down it's all
online
um i can't go out to eat okay makes
sense i'll eat outside oh now i can't go
outside because now there's a stay at
home order
so you can't even leave the house okay
cool um i'll just i'll just i can't go
to the margin enough
okay i can't fly now you can fly right
they can't
legally tell you not to fly but if you
if you leave the country you gotta pay
two thousand dollars to come back
in canada at least so i won't fly
right so i don't know man subhanallah
just it's getting more and more
oppressive and restrictive in the name
of being
liberalized and free yeah instead of
going forward they're going backwards
actually that's that's for sure that's
how it is from the last one i don't know
that that's that's why i
actually you know i every time this has
become
topic number one of course of discussion
which is obvious why
but i don't know i don't know i mean
indeed
i had hoped that this year would be a
year where we could travel again
a year of being able to uh to go abroad
but until the day after today until now
because we're already in april
i haven't seen i have been
i haven't been inside of the plane since
last march 2020
and this is abnormal for me normally i
would be every month somewhere else
and at this moment i haven't been
traveling for the last more than a year
um how long is this going to last and
this affects also financially because
don't forget
that um when i travel i don't have this
other holiday
i'm going to give lectures i sell my
books i i
i i it's financially
very important to me so it has affected
us all
it has affected us all yeah and i'm just
hoping that
we're going back to normal i just hope
that there will be a kind of normality
again
that's all we can say in sha allah this
far
write down hashtag mark travel
and uh we thank you so much i just
wanted to get one point out there that
um actually you know what i don't know
travel
[Laughter]
yes like i said in the beginning before
we even started the video a vibe with
you brother
i got a love for you i think well i you
have a an
amazing energy amazing energy
i just like love it i hope we'll see
each other there
life so we can also touch each other
us yes i'm looking forward to that
but you but actually you're in florida
man you must have great weather down
there come on
oh well right now i don't know if you
guys noticed but it got really dark
because it's about to
be a thunderstorm but um when you when
you mentioned the whole covert thing
i was going like this because uh it's
alhamdulillah it's actually not bad at
all
y'all are lucky bro yeah i'm over here
able to do my martial arts training
was like face to face yeah and listen
i'm i'm giving thanks to a lot every
single day that i can do that because
there's a lot of places where again
lockdown is still going on and people
can't do martial arts
they can't do that face-to-face thing
[Music]
what happened i said i can't even go to
the mosque yeah
it's probably you know so there's no
lockdown actually with you
is that there hasn't been a lockdown
since um
i i want to say since like this time
last year
the the first lockdown we had one
lockdown for like
two to four weeks and that's it
yeah and then everything just kind of
started opening up but i mean if you
guys
look at the statistics supposedly
because florida did that
we had the highest cases of kovid
for like a very long period of time
because we didn't implement
the lockdown but then again like if you
look at all the places that are still
doing lockdowns like y'all still got
coverage
you guys you guys you guys are lower now
than the than countries that are or
other states because you guys built
what's called herd immunity
right i know um you know dr secretary
i'm sure you're you know you're a
doctoral dude your phd
you've got your academic background so
when you when you see things that are
like
clinical studies right scientific
literature maps he says she says things
that are published
right there's there's definitely they're
they're legit they're authentic so
you know there was a new research paper
that i that i found i just want to end
it with this
last week my roommate sent it to me and
it says one in three
covered survivors will get
one diagnosed mental you know illness
within the six months within the first
six months and i was like yo that's
crazy
one in three coveted survivors will get
some
mental illness from from the virus but
here's the thing
is correlation causation because could
it just be from lockdown from social
isolation
because anxiety what they call anxiety
that's technically a disorder but
we all got anxiety bro we all got some
type of depression living at home not
you know so who knows all i'm trying to
say is when you see one in three
um you know covet survivors will get
some mental illness within the six
months
that's automatically going to get people
more scared of covid but is it really
that or is it
the lockdown is it the quarantine is it
the you know social
distancing whatever you want to call it
yeah
absolutely i mean um we are social
animals right
so we would like to go out i would like
to be in a restaurant again i've been
restaurants since since last
year i think february or something um
and i'm not talking about some kind of
fancy things i'm just talking about
socializing with people going in and
have some
have a meal together for example um that
is it it does affect you and it will
affect you and of course as you said
just now
i mean it's not covey that affects you
but it's a situation
is what you made out of that you know so
it's not kobe necessarily
but um you know i don't
i don't know the thing is let's we have
to make a lot of
a lot of dua really that things can go
back to normality
but the thing is when they go back to
normality for us let's say they go back
to a melody in europe they go back to
romanity in north america
but about the rest of the world i mean
if they cannot afford vaccines
let's just say or if you cannot travel
anymore to certain places because of the
fear
again this is an effect on you on
psychologically
and this is again not healthy so allah
i don't know i don't know where this is
going to end up really
no one knows what's going to happen but
uh safe to say it's gonna go down in
history
oh yes okay hashtag marked
okay until next time uh
write down some stuff in the comments to
all our viewers that you want to see in
the series coming up with dr
steph cares insha allah in the future
what different topics you want to see
um things you have questions all that
keep them in mind
uh and stay tuned for that rami i'm
gonna end it off but just like look here
for making the time to
come in this episode spit
your truth share your life share your
feelings and
be relatable and you know share stuff
that's easily digestible so people don't
lose track
you know as as a content creator now
i feel like you know when you make an
episode we can tell which ones are going
to have higher engagement right
so for example this episode as we're
recording i could tell
a lot of people are going to stick
through when most other videos they
might have clicked out you know
because there was a good pace there was
good momentum so thank you for that
indeed it was an honor and a pleasure
being here
and inshallah first but not last time so
i
definitely i'm looking forward to the
next time and
yes well let's let's enjoy as much as we
can because
let's forget about lockdown things
insha'allah inshallah this will go once
and then we will be able to also greet
each other like each other
all right alhamdulillah to you to all
the viewers
may allah bless you all with that being
s
when my mom had gotten surgery she got
part of her liver removed
she was out of commission for a year
and the entire time like i didn't do
anything for her
i was just basically hanging out with my
girlfriend
going to parties doing drugs drinking
spending time with friends basically
ducking her and my sister
was taking care of her the entire time
now
my sister didn't say anything but like
after the fact years later i reflected
on that myself and i was like damn like
that was really rough you know that was
really
rough for me to do that to my own mother
i'd probably be questioned about that on
the day of judgment
and like that's me being a
self-reflective person
being able to see that but like if my
sister would have said
what i had told you to say like i'm sure
at that moment in time it would've hit
[Music]
um
[Music]
hmm